I am sick of seeing sewage in our
beautiful beaches and rivers here in
Brighton their message is a clear one
these campaigners are protesting against
sewage spills in a demonstration
organized by Surfers against sewage the
paddle borders kayakers and swimmers are
calling for bathing Waters to be
protected from raw sewage it's a really
important time right now for protesting
on water quality we've finally got the
public to notice we've got communities
nursing we've even got media Outlets
running their own campaigns the time is
now to make the water companies notice
the government and regulators and
actually enact some change that's why
they also want to see sewage discharges
as a whole cut by 90 in the next seven
years their demands come days after the
industry apologized the water companies
have pledged 10 billion pounds to
cleaning up their act but with more than
300 000 sewage stores in England alone
last year these protesters are skeptical
it's going to make any real change
but it should be a safe place to swim
should be a safe place to paddle board
but it's not and we've lost you know
months of good swimming last year my
daughter got sick in a river last year
the profits at the water countries are
taking that the shareholders are taking
and that that money needs to be spent on
infrastructure protests were held across
the UK including here in Scarborough
where things looked a little different
we're not allowed
the water here is currently deemed to be
too dangerous but that didn't stand in
anyone's way there's concerns over what
this all means for the local economy the
water companies are going to have to put
an end to it because tourists are coming
here and forgot to be told that they
can't go in the sea then where are they
going to go this is the primary reason
why people come to the seaside water UK
are adamant that this time they will get
it right in a statement the chair of the
organization said the message from the
water and sewage industry is clear we
are sorry more should have been done to
address the issue of spillages sooner
and the public is right to be upset
about the current quality of our rivers
and beaches we have listened and have an
unprecedented plan to start to put it
right
it's clear that resolving the problem
will take time but this may well be the
point we see a turn of the tide Aisha
zahid Sky News in Brighton